البذور هي اصغر دول امريكا الوسطى لكن مع
هذا فهي من اعلى الدول العالم في معدلات
الجريمه ورقم واحد على العالم في معدلات
جرائم القتل وهي من اخطر الدول ونسبه
الجريمه في عاليه جدا والاف والاف السكان
اعضاء في عصابات ولما نجيب بوكل جاء رئيس
في 2019 وعد بحرب على الجريمه المنظمه
وانه يخلص البذور اكثر دول امريكا الوسطى
امانا ويبدو انه شغال على خطته فمن وقتها
وشغال الحملات الامنيه ضدهم واعتقل للان
64 الف من اعضاء العصابات هذه وبنى سجن
سمي بمركز سجن الارهاب هذا سجن عملاق راح
يشير اكثر من 40 الف سجين ومن كم يوم نقل
السجن اول 2000 عضو من اعضاء العصابات في
مشهد حقيقه الفيديوهات والصور منه كانها
طالعه من فيلم اكشن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شفت التنظيم مع الموسيقى مع اشكال
المجرمين كده حافيين بالتتوهات الكثيره
المخيفه وحلقين راسها ورجولهم مربطه يعني
كده فعليا مثل الافلام